[Music]
thank you
the ending of Philip K Dick's novel The
Man in the High Castle is going to
conclude with us encountering this
almost legendary character Robinson the
author of the grasshopper lies heavy
which is one of the main books that is
being
referenced read discussed within Philip
K Dick's novel and there's another book
The Oracle or the Aging the book of
changes that also plays a massively
important role in what we see in the end
is that the two of these are not as
distinct as we have been led to think
over the course of the work and it's
Juliana Frank who is going to figure
this out and in a certain sense go
beyond what both of the abensons have
have figured out themselves let's try
this all from the start all right
in the very final chapter
you okay
go ahead
oh
in the very final chapter of Philip K
Dick's alternate history novel The Man
in the High Castle we get to meet the
man in the High Castle no longer living
in one along with his wife Robinson the
author of one of the two really
important books mentioned consulted read
within this novel The Grasshopper lies
heavy which is itself an alternate
history which presents a world in which
Nazi Germany and Imperial Japan didn't
win World War II but instead it is the
United States of America and Britain the
British Empire who Triumph in the end so
an alternate history to an alternate
history that we're reading and the other
main book that is constantly invoked
it's going to turn out to be closely
related to the grasshopper lies heavy
and that is the orc Circle or the Aging
or the book of changes and the the main
person who is going to figure this out
whose eyes and thought were going to get
this through interactions is Juliana
Frank who constantly consults the Oracle
and so we need a little bit of stage
setting before we get to her encounter
with the author and his wife
so in Chapter 13
she has already killed Joe the secret
agent who is trying to get them to the
Robinson so that he can actually kill
this author and she thinks to herself
why didn't I consult the Oracle too bad
I didn't consult the Oracle it would
have known and warned me why didn't I at
any time I could have asked any place
along the trip or even before we left
she began to moan involuntarily the
noise of howling she'd never heard issue
out of her before horrified her but she
could not suppress it even though she
clamped her teeth together a ghastly
chanting singing wailing rising up
through her nose and so she's going
through something almost like a
spiritual or shamanic experience with uh
her grief her anguish and wishing she
had used this you know possibility of
tapping into reality itself so she in
fact does get out her Euro stocks and
gets out the two volumes of the Oracle
and asks it what'll I do tell me what to
do please and we've already talked about
this elsewhere where it gives her you
know basically the Oracle says even more
emphatically get up to Cheyenne and
Warren Robinson however dangerous it is
to me I must bring him the truth now
what is the truth at this point the SD
the sacred Dean's Heist are after him
and they want to kill him so she is
going to get on her way and then in
chapter 15 we find that she finishes the
book his book The Grasshopper lies heavy
she made herself comfortable in the
motel room turning on the radio getting
coffee from the motel lunch counter she
propped herself on the neatly made bed
with a new unread clean copy of the
grasshopper which she'd bought at the
hotel Bookshop in Denver at 6 15 in the
evening she finished the book and now we
get to something really critical I
wonder if Joe got to the end of it she
wondered there's so much more in it than
he understood so okay not a surprise
that she is getting more out of it than
Joe himself is but now she goes on
further and she says what is it Robinson
wanted to say
nothing about his make-believe world his
fictional World in which the Allies have
won World War II and then she says am I
the only one who knows I bet I am
nobody else really understands Grant the
grasshopper but me they just imagine
that they do so we're not going to find
out what this realization on her part is
until a little bit later in chapter 15
when she shows up at the Robinsons And
you know she's let inside
and then there's going to be a series of
important
questions that are being asked and kind
of answered right so first she asks
abenson
um Hawthorne Adamson do you know the
Oracle And he says no and she says the
book of changes I don't know and then
Carolyn Adamson says don't tease her and
then Juliana says I read your book in
fact I finished it this evening how did
you know all that about the other world
that you wrote about and then she asked
did you use the Oracle to do that
Hawthorne glanced at her I don't want
you to kid her joke tell me without
making something witty out of it and we
should pause here for a second so
Adamson is rarely going to give
Hawthorne Robinsons rarely going to give
straight answers to Juliana in fact it's
his wife Carolyn who is going to supply
the missing information and there's kind
of two levels of obsification here or
misdirection you could say one is being
witty or Bane right being superficial
the other is
misdirecting at a deeper level and so
this is very interesting so
um
he gazes down at the floor everybody
else has become silent and then he says
that's a hard question to answer and
Juliana says no it's not so we've got a
conflict already there and he says I'm
sorry I can't answer right away you'll
have to accept that so then she changes
to another line of questioning
why did he write the book
what was going on there
and he again Mr exit what's that pin on
your dress do ward off dangerous anima
Spirits out of the immutable world or
does it just hold everything together
and then she says
why do you change the subject evading
what I asked you and making a pointless
remark like that it's childish and then
Hawthorne abenson says everybody has
technical secrets you have yours I have
mine and now he gives some advice about
how the book is what it should be read
right his intention as an author his
Direction you should read my book and
accept it on face value just as I accept
what I see without inquiring if it's
genuine underneath there or done with
wires and staves and foam rubber padding
isn't that part of trusting in the
nature of people and what you see in
general
and now notice how dick describes what's
going on here he seemed no she thought
irritable and flustered now no longer
polite no longer a host and Carolyn she
noticed out of the corner of her eye had
an expression of tense exasperation her
lips were pressed together and she'd
stopped smiling entirely now this is
going to carry on through the rest
so Juliana says
in your book you showed there's a way
out isn't that what you meant now a way
out of what a way out of the world the
reality that they're in
and
erson says out he echoed ironically
Juliana says then you've done a lot for
me now I can see there's nothing to be
afraid of nothing to want or hate or
avoid hear or run from or pursue which
is an interesting way of talking about
things and we should pause on that for a
moment what is she actually
mentioning what is she actually
referencing in this so they're caught
within a world that is essentially a
dystopia right a world that seems to be
the only reality as opposed to the
fiction the projection the fantasy that
is represented in the grasshopper lies
heavy
she's saying that this book is showing
that there's a way out and that affects
things in this world and so he says
there's a great deal in this world worth
the candle in my opinion and she says I
understand what's going on in your mind
and then she tells the story of you know
the SD and and killing Joe and uh you
know the fact that they're going to be
hunting him and then they move on back
to another key question
she says
the Oracle wrote your book
didn't it
and then Hawthorne says do you want the
truth
she says I wanted and I'm entitled to it
for what I've done isn't that so you
know it so and then abenson says the
Oracle was sound asleep all through the
writing of the book sound asleep in the
corner of the office his eyes showed no
merriment and said his face seemed
longer more somber than ever so before
he was making you know weedy humorous
remarks now he's still trying to
misdirect her trying to lead her away
but it's no longer in a happy convivial
way and then Carolyn says tell her she's
entitled to know for what she did on
your behalf I'll tell you then Mrs Frank
one by one
cloth Hawthorne Robinson made the
choices
thousands of them
how by means of the lines historic
period subject characters plot it took
years Hoth even asked the Oracle what
sort of success it would be it told them
that it would be a very great success
the first real one of his career so you
were right now notice the next thing
that she says to her you must use the
Oracle quite a lot yourself to have no
that's the realization that we had back
in the earlier part of chapter 15. so
Juliana Frank realizes something that
nobody else has so far about the book
except for the abensons which is at the
Oracle itself
was not just used for writing the book
The Oracle was
directing the writing of the book
so Hawthorne himself
is going to say that you know they they
came to an agreement regarding royalties
but Juliana's going to say okay so why
would the oracle
write a book
what's the point in that did you ever
think of asking it that and why one
about the Japanese and Germans losing
the war why that particular story and no
other one what is there it can't tell us
directly like it always has before this
must be different don't you think now
that is a very fateful line isn't it a
realization the Oracle has been telling
characters in this story you know
Juliana Frank
tagomi others as well what they ought to
be doing how to interpret the situations
that they are finding themselves in this
is broader this is about the entire
world and the implications of this book
for the world so
um Carolyn then says I'll ask it if you
won't and Hawthorne says it's not your
question he's telling his wife this to
ask let her ask Julianna so he says you
have an unnatural mind are you aware of
that and they talk a little bit about
how they do the Divination and then we
get to the key question now she's going
to ask the Oracle two questions
Oracle why did you write the grasshopper
lies heavy that's the first one
the second one what are we human beings
supposed to learn from the grasshopper
lies heavy from your writing of it from
the why of that so she throws the coins
and she gets the hexagram
what is it inner truth and she says I
know without using the chart and I know
what it means raising his head Hawthorne
scrutinized her he had now an almost
Savage expression it means does it that
my book is true yes she said with anger
he said Germany and Japan lost the war
yes
and then Julianna says even you don't
face it he says well I'm not sure of
anything she says believe
he shook his head no can't you she said
are you sure
and then he says well do would you like
me to autograph the book so he's once
again misdirecting he's once again
evading right
but what's going on here
the book is true in the sense that the
world that they're living in
is not actually the real world now we
also
got to see this to a certain extent with
Mr tagumi's experience of a world where
Japan and Germany had lost the war as
well
there's one other feature that we want
to focus on here as the book is ending
the man in the High Castle
as she's putting her coat on Hawthorne
appeared behind her do you know what you
are
he turned to Carolina Stood Beside him
this girl is a diamond a little cathonic
spirit that roams tirelessly over the
face of the Earth she's doing what's
instinctive to her simply expressing her
being she didn't mean to show up here
and do harm it simply happened to her
just as weather happens to us I'm glad
she came I'm not sorry to find this out
this Revelation that she's had through
the book she didn't know what she was
going to do here or find out I think all
of us are lucky so let's not be angry
about it okay so he is trying to put
aside his own anger
and then Carol and his wife says she's
terribly terribly disruptive and her
author and responds so is reality right
they talk a little bit about whether he
should take a hand weapon or not and
what she might be doing later on and
then uh she's she's talking Carolyn
brings us up despite what you did for us
or what you say you did
you wished I had never come into this
house Julianna said if you saved
Hawthorne's life it's Dreadful of me but
I'm so upset I can't take it all in what
you've said and Hawthorne has said and
here we get to a really interesting
observation that'll close these
Reflections how strange Juliana said I
never would have thought the truth would
make you angry truth she thought as
terrible as death but harder to find I'm
lucky I thought you'd be as pleased and
excited as I am a misunderstanding isn't
it she smiled and after a pause Mrs
abinson managed to smile back well good
night anyhow so we see a range of
reactions to this realization that the
world that they're in is not truly the
real world even though it appears real
even though it has its own tissue its
own fabric of realness or reality there
is yet another reality that is more real
and it's not some sort of you know
transcendental thing it's another world
that in which the the Allies actually
won World War II and that world
that's revealed at least partly through
the grasshopper lies heavy is indeed the
real world the world of the book
is more real than the world in which
they read the book and think about the
book and ask the Oracle about the book
and all of this is happening of course
within the scope of Philip Philip K
Dick's alternate history novel where
we've got these very interesting
interplays between different worlds
different histories different timelines
and the Aging or Oracle the book of
changes
exercising a certain kind of agency
leading to Robinson writing this book
Guided by the Divination that the Oracle
is providing
so what we have here is a revelation and
reactions to it on the part of some of
the main characters